but I school I'm blowing up obstacles
and building bridges in just a few
minutes to capabilities that the German
army is bringing to Trident juncture but
are these old-school skills still needed
in times of hybrid warfare and cyber
attacks as a result after the Ukraine
crisis we saw that it is more important
to change back from stability operations
to higher tens of warfare operations at
what we see and there's an interest to
move larger formations and heavy
equipment and this had not been trained
and done within the last ten years far
from the Russian border Germany has set
up its operational headquarters in the
Norwegian hinterlands together with
troops from France the Netherlands
Belgium and Latvia Germany alone has
brought 10,000 soldiers up here to
Norway in addition to tanks weapons and
other supplies
it's a massive logistical challenge
designed to improve the speed with which
NATO members could in a worst-case
scenario
come to each other's rescue the huge
influx of people and equipment more than
50,000 soldiers from 31 countries is a
true test for the host nation Norway but
the attitude among the public is
thoroughly positive support for NATO
here is among the highest of all Member
States and not just because Norway
shares a border with Russia we're not so
afraid that it will be a war not now but
it's a lot of things happening in the
world so you never know so NATO is
important for us of course well I
believe Russia's become a big threat in
the last two years and I wouldn't I need
we need to show where power I gave this
war in the world and I know I could be
part of it but it's not like it's
something I think about it
but some of NATO's tested capacities are
hidden
remote-controlled weapon systems
self-driving vehicles
military drones so is this the future of
warfare all those capabilities have to
be reversible it means that the the
forces can rely on this capability and
have have to know how to do without
those capabilities because the the older
system can be jammed or destroyed or
taken by the by by someone else so the
military have to remain reversible and
that's why the airlines are still
banking on tanks and boots on the ground
battling daunting logistics and the
elements here in the frigid Norwegian
climate